so speaking of college there is an
excellent professor a law professor at
Faulkner University named Adam McLean
who insists that any student who uses
the phrase I feel instead of I think
must cluck like a chicken and if they
use isms you know those is this is Amman
that ISM or if they use vague trendy
words like fair diversity etc they must
immediately stop and explain what they
think I noticed this in college to for
comment we turn to every millennial okay
like right now for example the Hayden's
need to come to America but some people
are all what about the strain on our
resources and it's like when I had this
garden party for my father's birthday
right that is so profound that really
changed the way I think about things you
know like Alicia yeah you might have
noticed this too if the language has
changed now people don't say I think
we're I believe all the time it's all
bad but they'll you know I feel like it
would be better if we do this I feel
like this was kind of interesting why
the change why do Millennials only use
the phrase I feel I blame the public
education system I also think that
clucking like a chicken is not
punishment enough because let's be
honest drunk people do the chicken dance
at weddings all across America yeah your
cameras out of my apartment oh you just
do them in your apartment wow I like
prepping a dance for your wedding time
entails in school but I I think that it
is definitely something to do with what
we see on TV what we what our generation
has read in media what we you know
romantic comedies even that like women
are raised from seeing from the 80s and
Beyond not that romantic comedies aren't
amazing but it does kind of teach this
and reinforce this belief that
everything is about feeling versus facts
like our buddy Ben says yeah for this
Amanda she's just somewhere I think it
might be a pinch tweet somewhere and and
I think that that is really continued
over and it's something that you see
continually in the education system I
mean I'm looking at schools right now
for my four-year-old and every every
single tour the two questions that are
given the most time is the diversity
question and what about the feelings of
the students and I'm like no not what
about the feelings of the students what
are you gonna do to get my
kid into Harvard you know a professor of
mine in college had a theory on all of
this he this guy Charles Hill he's a
lifelong diplomat ambassador and his his
idea was that over time students have
become much more afraid just to make any
statements of fact they're they're too
afraid because they think that the facts
can be offensive so you used to say the
sky is blue and then you could say well
I I think the sky is blue you know
that's just my opinion and we still I
believe the sky is blue because belief
is a little a little more wish washy and
then ultimately you get I feel like the
sky's blue even the word like which we
make fun of the valley girl well isn't
it like this and that even though we're
like is distancing yourself it's it's a
simile you're not saying the thing is
what it is you're saying it's like
something else and that gives you a lot
of wiggle room now Allie you are a
conservative millennial I've read
somewhere is it that Millennials are
afraid of making statements of fact they
seem hysterical in in many ways what
what is going on here with the
relationship of Millennials to objective
truth I do think it's like you and you
have both noted this kind of
popularization of subjectivity and kind
of shame about being objective and it's
not just objectivity but we're so afraid
of being judgemental the worst thing you
can be after being a racist and a bigot
at a homophobe is being judgmental so
you see that anything is right or wrong
especially if you're on the right um
that you're not only a big but you are
you know you're morally wrong and so I
think it is in an effort to avoid being
judgmental or being called a bigot or
what have you and people start with I
feel like or I think it's also something
that you learn in like conflict
resolution or if you go to like
premarital counseling they always tell
you to start with I feel because it
takes the responsibility off of the
person that you're talking to it's like
I feel like you're being really rude I
mean that's just my feeling but I feel
like it um so I think that's trying to
what we're going for we're so afraid of
conflict we're so afraid of objectivity
we're so afraid of being called a bigot
or judgmental but if we're just starting
with our own feelings you can't get mad
at me for that it's kind of like so you
no offense and you're actually being
really great people only say that when
they're being extremely offensive you
know is it well no offense don't
whatever you're gonna say don't say
we've got to bless your heart I think
it's also because people don't
understand what an opinion is anymore
we learn this incorrectly in schools
that people think in an opinion is a
preference so they think you know if I
could say the sky is blue that's a fact
I can say I think the sky is blue that's
an opinion but it's a true opinion now
if I say I like the blue sky or the blue
sky sky pleases me I guess that's a
preference I prefer cheese sandwiches to
ham sandwiches that's a preference but
just say I think and then a statement of
fact that's an opinion but an opinion
states fact now Jacob this is a very
frustrating issue when you talk to
Millennials about this they want
conflict resolution just as Ali has said
but sometimes you need to push you need
to push arguments to their extreme to
actually get to an answer to actually
see the world clearly what is to blame
for this why are Millennials so afraid
of conflict is it is it the helicopter
parenting is hit the anti-bullying
campaigns why are we so afraid of
getting MIDI and gritty in arguments
with people I think it has to do with a
pop culture honestly I mean even if you
grew up in the 90s like I did and you
had the greatest version of the Disney
Channel original series you use every
problem is solved in 20 minutes or less
right and so whenever a problem goes
beyond that 20 minute mark you're like
where's I need a commercial break right
now so I think that it has to do with I
just want to resolve this quickly or it
gets uncomfortable and just like and
also has something to do with a tally
said being judgmental we don't want to
come off as judgmental even if we know
we're right so when we say oh a bortion
is murder and then a leftist says well
that's judgmental you're judging someone
you're like well I'm judging whether the
fact that this person has
life or not and if that life has
intrinsic value and I think my judgment
is correct and we just need a
Millennials need to not be afraid
especially conservative Millennials need
to not be afraid to stand up and say
look this might not be solved in twenty
minutes or less we're just gonna have to
work it out and get all the facts
it is totally an example of politics
following culture of the culture being
so insidious in ways we can't recognize
I hadn't even considered that and on the
judge eNOS they don't be judgy don't be
judgmental you hear this phrase
sometimes now which is don't you um
don't ya don't say that the thing I like
is disgusting or something and the
logical conclusion of this is what
happened in the 20th century is a major
movement among leftist intellectuals to
normalize pedophilia and now obviously
this is in the air with they say that
Roy Moore I guess that wasn't pedophilia
that was probably close to benefits a
fee Buffy Lee as post-pubescent girls
but nevertheless girls who were too
young to be having sex with and you're
picking them up there was this movement
to normalize all of that and we should
yuck that YUM if somebody finds that
yummy let's yuck it man we can't we
can't have too much of that